new TSA security screening technology is
being tested today just before what's
expected to be a record-breaking holiday
travel season the scanning system is
designed to spot hidden explosives and
suicide vests similar to the one used in
Monday's botched terror attack in a
pedestrian tunnel right here in New York
the equipment is now being tested in Los
Angeles but it's been tried at major
rail hubs all around the country
including Washington DC Kris Van Cleave
is inside Washington's Union Station
right now Kris good morning
good morning whether it is an airport a
subway station or a transit hub like
Union Station here in Washington you
have a common problem what do you do
with these public areas where anyone can
gather you can use police and bomb
sniffing dogs but it remains a
vulnerability one the TSA is hoping
technology can help solve the video of
Monday's pipe bomb attack in New York
City makes clear the danger as it goes
off in a crowded tunnel it's the kind of
suicide bomber style attack this system
is designed to try to stop using cameras
to scan people entering a transit system
for dense items concealed under their
clothing like an explosive vest and
we're really looking for those alarm
indicators and so as that bar turns from
green to red we know we've identified an
individual that may need a little closer
scrutiny
Alex Wiggins is the head of security for
LA's Transit Authority we can encounter
that person as they enter the station in
the mezzanine we could very very quickly
isolate them and move to the area where
if there is a threat that we can
actually contain that much better the
technology is currently being tested at
Los Angeles is busy 7th Street Metro
Center station where four of the
region's commuter lines connect more
than 86,000 passengers move through here
each weekday the scanners are designed
to operate in the background passively
scanning people walking by in real time
without using radiation there's no
silver bullet no technical silver bullet
to prevent all acts of terrorism but
clearly as part of a layered defense it
can play a role in at least making it
harder for the bad guys tsa is hopeful
new technology will lead to better
detection be it at a train station or an
airport this scanner is current
being tested at a TSA facility outside
Washington DC the goal is eventually to
be able to scan people as they pass by
so what you want is a scanner where
people can just keep walking and just
keep walking and they don't even really
notice that they're being screened why
they're doing it the TSA says Amtrak
used the scanners here at Union Station
during the busy Thanksgiving holiday
travel season we know that New Jersey
Transit has also tried out the scanners
the TSA says more testing will be needed
John Kris Van Cleave thanks